so continuing our discussion on the
books of doom the version of Doctor Doom
that you guys know and love the guy with
the best one-liners with a very arrogant
cocky attitude we get that doom finally
and the first thing we get is we get
that doom in spectacular fashion as dew
makes his way from Tibet you know to his
homeland of Latveria where the Romani
territories were that he had grown up in
as a child when he comes back he finds
that things really aren't that different
that you know the Russians are still
running the show than a lot of those
individuals who were previously free are
now being used as prisoners for the
purpose of you know railroad work of
different things like that in a lot of
ways this was par for the course during
Russian society during this time because
the Russian society had always struggled
under the communist regime of of Lenin
and Leon Trotsky followed by Joseph
Stalin you know and even under Nikita
Khrushchev there had always been
struggles in terms of the economic
inequalities and this is really just
what we're seeing here we're seeing this
same premise being applied to the comics
but when do makes his appearance known
what he says is that he had spent you
know a week or so looking at the
entirety of the landscape trying to
figure the best way to make his presence
known
does he simply show up and just start
killing soldiers or does he rally people
to his side and any smart leader that's
going to take over any territory knows
the best way to take over that territory
is to rally the common people to your
side against the existing establishment
and this is what doom does as soon as he
goes in he immediately makes his
presence known to soldiers and he stands
with his back to them facing the enemy
and that right there is an indication to
them that he's on their behalf he's not
facing them he's facing the other guys
and so as he goes against these soldiers
the initial idea from them is they don't
know who he is they don't know where
he's from they don't know what he's
about he's just a guy in a metal suit
and a green cloak and he seems like he's
a crazy person one of the guys and this
is why I love this so much one of the
guys responds what the devil and doom
says I have seen Devils and believe me
doom is something else altogether and
this is why I love Doctor Doom because
he has the best lines and he said them
so arrogantly it just works it
this works so well but what he does is
he makes quick work of these soldiers
and as soon as all these guys are dead
he immediately turns his sights to some
of the workers now some of them
recognize him some of them know who he
is whether it's because of rumors that
circulated around of his ongoings when
he was a child and casting out the
soldiers or because some actually hail
from a his Romani territory
the fact remains that doom tells them
spread the word tell everyone throughout
the land that doom is here and that doom
will not suffer you guys to bondage
anymore that doom is effectively going
to free them from the yoke of oppression
and he is going to rule Latveria justly
and so what he does is he kind of makes
his last rites he kind of makes his last
rounds he begins circulating around he
begins going to visit you know different
places of course visits the grave the
children who had died you know during
the night of his mom's selling her soul
and booking magic he's just kind of
getting his bearings on you know where
Liberia is now versus where it was that
he remembers it being and so after this
is done he goes back to the temple and
he begins his planning he begins his
process of going through and analyzing
what's the best way to take out Latveria
and so the first thing he does the thing
that seems to make the most sense after
you know spreading the word around the
city or around the around the nation is
he travels back to his caravan now again
not everybody in this caravan was taken
some of them were but some of them also
managed to escape and rebuild because
again at this point in in Russian
society a lot of Romani caravans would
band together for the sake of protection
simply because there's strength in
numbers and it just makes practical
sense but at the same time they also
wanted to live a life that was more free
from the stringent constraints of what
they saw under the communist regime of
the existing leaders at the time and so
he initially meets with a guy named
Boris now again Boris was one of the
people that wanted to cast doom out and
doom had made the promise to them that
when he came back if they had done that
that he would lay waste to their Caravan
but because they didn't he comes to them
as a saviour more so than a man who's
going to lay waste to everything they
know and so what he does is he presents
himself to them he basically says here
are the things that I'm capable of here
are the things that I can do here's how
I can help you you know escape
oppression and here's how I can help you
live the life that you've been wanting
to live this entire time and so
after sending word throughout the town
again this is just a continuation of him
bolstering forces bolstering the common
people to his side now the once he
travels back to his realm once he
travels back to his to his base of
operations he's met by the return of
valerian now for valaria things have
changed irrevocably things just simply
aren't the way they were before the
Victor Von Doom that she knew has long
since been gone and this is actually a
really really cool part of the story
because for for characters like valaria
it allows us to see how much things have
changed and what I mean by that is we
follow Doctor Doom and yes we can see
progressions in his character yes we can
see his character change but we don't
quite understand how much his character
is changed until someone else comes
along that hasn't seen him for quite
some time it's like losing weight you
know like you said you you go to the gym
you work out every single day you don't
necessarily see the weight loss but if
you take a picture once every month and
then look at those pictures over the
course of the year you'll notice a
dramatic increase in your size you know
as time progresses and so with Victor
Von Doom he's basically beyond the point
of help and valaria recognizes that she
says what you're doing here is not power
what you're doing here is not honoring
your mother is not honoring your family
you're basically just becoming the same
person that the Baron is just by
different means but doom doesn't see
that this way doom does not see himself
as the same kind of person as the Baron
doom he sees himself as a liberator
do sees himself as someone that can free
these people from oppression and can
make their lives better and so what he
does is he begins invoking again these
very primitive forms of doombots and has
them fight on behalf of the common
people as they lead revolt against the
existing establishment of course they
start tearing down statues things like
that but we end up transitioning over to
the Baron and what happens is the Baron
has also come to the recognition that
Victor Von Doom seems to be beyond his
ability to control but what also takes
place is the Baron receives a message
from doom doom tells the Baron that when
he was a child when doing was a child
that the Baron had taken dooms father
for the purpose of curing his wife of
cancer and that because dooms father was
not able to do that the Baron had dooms
father killed
and so what doom is saying is you've
basically made your own situation what
it is
have brought this on yourself and it was
inevitable that the time would come when
you would fall the question is who would
take him down and so as this particular
issue begins to come to an end we move
with Victor Von Doom as he loses his
base of operations temporarily it stands
out on a balcony and is met by thousands
thousands of people from across the land
who have rallied under him allowing him
to overtake the baron and to become the
undisputed ruler of Latveria now because
issue number five was relatively short
on you know exposition that we could
really discuss I'm gonna go ahead and
just throw issue number six in here and
let us continue to the stories
conclusion and this is really cool
I think you guys are really going to dig
this so what happens is of course you
know with doom rallying all these common
people to his side the battle lines have
been drawn is basically the forces of
the baron versus the forces of Victor
Von Doom not only that in every instance
where someone rises to power if they
rise to power using oppression the
circumstance will always come to
fruition whereby individuals among their
own ranks will look to break away
they'll look to leave now they may wait
until someone of greater power comes
along but in the end that oppressive
ruler will always see their own
destruction and this is exactly what
happens with the forces of the King's
Men being almost decimated by the by the
forces of Doctor Doom alongside his
magic and his technology what we learn
is that some of the forces of the King
feel the exact same way as the common
people they're tired of being oppressed
they're tired of living under a baron
that's so tyrannical and so what happens
is some of these soldiers actually
defect away from the king and bolster
the side of Victor Von Doom and so in
truth for the Baron from his perspective
this is really just an instance where by
its it's only a matter of time before he
loses everything but even then he's
still unwilling to admit defeat and the
reason why is because within the castle
what he says is that no one has breached
the walls of that castle for over a
hundred years and so it seems virtually
impossible not only that the forces of
you know the Baron they have tanks they
have advanced weapons or at least modern
weapons anyway and in his mind all these
con people have nothing but pitchforks
but in the end the
you hear is that because the soldiers of
the Baron have effectively turned
against him when the orders are given to
strike down the forces of Doctor Doom
they do not obey instead they ignore the
orders and they allow Doctor Doom to
march headlong into the castle gates and
to kill the Baron now this is a really
really cool moment because again this
sees Doctor Doom choking this man to
death with his very hands which is kind
of a homage to the first time that he
killed a person but more so than that we
also see that Doctor Doom is effectively
christened you know as the ruler of
Latveria but over time because of the
fact that the castle seemed to have been
been totally laid waste too because of
the fact that there had been so much
struggling so much suffering Doctor Doom
has the entire area rebuilt and he
basically turns it into a land of his
own individual people he turns it into a
land that is people control he is a
ruler he does have absolute law or he
does have absolute control but the
people that he rules don't look at him
as a ruler they look at him as a leader
and there's a huge difference there in
truth depending on on who it is we're
talking about there are some rebel
factions that don't necessarily agree
with doom but on the whole the people
that are subservient to him do so
willingly and they would gladly in a lot
of instances lay down their lives in
order to ensure that doom maintains his
rule because they know the alternative
could be that much worse and so what
happens is as this story begins to come
to a close we learn that after becoming
Doctor Doom in his entirety that dooms
summons a projection of the demon entity
Mephisto and Mephisto says that he's
been watching doom he's seen what Doom
has become and he begins to taunt him a
little bit but doom doesn't want to hear
anything about it but what he says is
that he'll give doom an opportunity to
fight for his mother's soul Doom will be
given the chance once every year to
travel to the realm of Mephisto battle
Mephisto and if doom is successful he
will be able to bring his mother's soul
back now again this ties into why doom
was always pursuing absolute power so
for those of you guys who were curious
as to why doom was trying to capture the
power and beyonders or why he'd been
trying to get his hands on the Infinity
Gauntlet it wasn't really for dominating
the world that was maybe a ploy that he
had at some point in time but it was
always to harness the power that would
allow him to travel to the realm of
Mephisto and defeat Mephisto and get his
mother's soul back that was
really the reason why he ever did any of
that stuff and so what happens again as
we start to wrap this up is we learn
that this entire interview is being done
by a reporter and that she is actually
talking to a Doombot not only that as
his explanation begins to come to an end
as it starts to wind up she talks to
Bors and what Boris says is that this
Doombot had basically gone rogue
that this Doombot had had basically
become too sentient kind of self-aware
and the result was that it was locked
away by the real dr. doom and so while
this reporter is being escorted out or
at least what she believes to be the
exit it turns out that she's actually
thrown in the prison cell and the reason
why is that dr. doom does not want
anybody to know about his past he does
not want anybody to know who he is or
where he came from he wants to remain
mysterious and he wants to remain inning
Matic and so as far as we know at least
as far as the story comes to an end this
woman is going to spend the rest of her
days in this prison cell as a prisoner
of Doctor Doom with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
don't know about you guys but I loved
books of doom
books of doom was such a solid story so
let me know the guys are interested in
seeing more content about Doctor Doom
I'm kind of curious and there she is at
the sub button become proud of the Rob
Ford java-like and we'll catch you guys
later peace
ah
[Music]